antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage
l'émission d'été de tirs hier du sang
[Musique]
le vieux piano de la place le jour quand
sonne quand solitude vieux pianos de la
place à des clients dont l'habitude de
danser
les autres jours ça sur les planches
devant la mer qui se souvient il rêve
son fait mais c'est alors le sang tout
court battu de ma cachette et peut
soudain de rang tremblante ému en lui je
m'arrête
mais c'était nous livre tout ce que je
retourne comme cette musique jali mais
proulx me fait du mal
me fait du bien non c'est un vieux piano
bonsoir bienvenue au bar de la plage
avec caen boujenah est en vacances il ne
fait pas du boujenah à l'été il ya le
ciel le soleil et la mer et lui
pleins feux sur les incendies de forêt
douche froide pour les pompiers la plage
à la page
andré bercoff ivres de livres les
aventures de lolo chez les blaireaux du
bord de l'eau très chaud pour les petits
marie leurs actions de maryse et le
barman qui ne l'ouvrent qu'à bon escient
[Applaudissements]
mieux
à
ces états à disney
alm quelle horreur
[Applaudissements]
avant de faire
jean marc ayrault
mais
m
et
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas
vous avez
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
jean marc jacot
là
e
[Musique]
ce soir gagner tv book philips répondait
en tapant 36 15 codes admis à la
question suivante on va chanter françois
de guérites à la rentrée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faites-moi dussollier spécial jacky
aussi les mains faites-moi 1 roland
giraud alors trop café théâtre monsieur
faites moi un couffin n'ai pas d'enfant
ces conditions remplies faites moi un
beau jeune et je vous préviens monsieur
je ne le sert jamais sans accent mais
pourquoi vivant et pour vraiment ah
[Musique]
voilà monsieur par michel boujenah
bonsoir bonsoir
alors tu es venu en bateau la wii
qu'est-ce qui pilote le bateau le
capitaine
ah bon tu mets pas le capitaine du
bateau annoncé vaut mieux pas tué le
propriétaire non plus ah bon c'est pas
nouveau bateau non mon bateau est plus
petits afin de capitaine en bateau à moi
c'est moi le capitaine mais c'est moins
dangereux parce que bateau est beaucoup
plus petit quand je range mon bateau au
port et bien qu'il soit très petits en
général ça dure au moins une demi-heure
et un général j'ai toujours tous les
types qui ont des bateaux au tour qui me
donne des conseils ce qui fait que ça
devient une catastrophe à une taille
humaine avec les créneaux beaucoup moins
parce qu'un bateau ça bouge tout le
temps et on n'a pas la besa freine pas
pu donc c'est l'enfer car poser là ça va
pas encore mais ça commence à aller
mieux
ah oui celle de l'aller j'ai arrêté le
théâtre ya trois semaines et j'en
pouvais plus en plus physiquement
j'étais au bout du rouleau
d'ailleurs ça se voyait jeu j'avais même
du mal à jouer quoi
en même temps c'était c'était une
aventure tellement forte du jury 185
fois dans l'année et c'était beaucoup
beaucoup trop et ça va laisser ta maison
de saint paul de vence la seule en beau
oui hein c'est à fait pas le choix cette
maison à peine tu l'as tu commences déjà
là qui connaît très bien sûr ça fait
deux ans mais
avant quand je jouais des maisons
j'avais du mal à partir parce que je
savais que c'était fini coup et là elle
est là ça fait qu'elle est là elle est
pas loin
elle est là et je sais que c'est chez
moi et c'est interdit c'est la première
fois que je pose mes valises
oui ça y est la taton oui c'est chez moi
c'est vraiment chez moi c'est drôle
parce que je me souviens d'un copain qui
est venu au tout début quand j'ai
commencé un besoin qui m'a dit la
location se termine quand alors cette
maison tu l'a rêvé tu l'a dessinée tu en
as surveiller la construction
oui et tu as dis je me suis saignée aux
quatre veines pour l'acheter we hate a
coûté cher comme tout le monde ça c'est
pas important
tu as dit plutôt que de la vendre je
préférerais repeindre des appartements
nuitées jours régine ce que certains dé
appartenait déjà les jours avoir déjà
fait donc c'est ce que c'est ah oui oui
tout à fait j'ai déjà fait j'ai fait
plein de trucs comme ça avant ouais je
n'aimerais pas et en même temps si si
pour la garder il faut que je fasse des
choses que j'aime pas ouais ou une
manière de travailler que j'aime pas eh
ben je la vendrai a quand même oui il ya
trop de gens qui ont sacrifié leur vie
des choses comme ça et dans mon métier
j'ai vu des gens comment dire avoir des
besoins avec le succès l'argent tous à
avoir des besoins puis tout d'un coup
avoir un peu moins de succès avoir les
mêmes besoins et commencer à faire
n'importe quoi et a plus travaillé comme
il avait envie de travailler
tout ça pour garder les conséquences du
succès je dirais c'est à dire le pognon
et et ça je pourrais pas que ça serait
le pire pour toi comme chose à faire que
je supporterai pas vraiment tu dirais
jeu suivant la maison ça serait quoi
par exemple une émission de télévision
être animateur de télévision par exemple
mais ça risque pas de m'arriver parce
que ça rit ça m'arrivait parce que je
pourrais pas faire c'est impossible je
suis trop nul pour ça ah oui tu crois
quoi ah oui oui je pourrais pas non ça
c'est le regarde pas sinon encore que
certains dis-moi pourquoi saint paul de
vence alors je suis tombé amoureux ça
s'est passé comment j'allais jouer à
nice et puis on m'a emmené des jeunes et
la colombe d'or et j'ai regardé en roulé
puis je regardais cet endroit j s
c'est beau puis j'y suis revenu quinze
jours après passer un week-end et puis
je dis tiens je vais répéter la alors
j'ai trouvé une salle de répétition à
nice et j'ai répété l'ange-gardien là
bas et puis j'ai commencé à connaître
des gens je me suis senti bien c'est à
cinq minutes de la mer c'est à dix
minutes de l'aéroport
tout est prêt pas loin de paris c'était
simple et puis j'ai eu un coup de chance
formidable j'ai trouvé un endroit ce qui
est très rare j'ai eu un coup de chance
incroyable c'était un coup qui s'étaient
disputés on peut se dire des gens fait
que c'est fou parce que les maisons
c'est fou il ya des gens ils deviennent
fous en construisant des maisons quand
c'est une meilleure existait déjà ah non
non non non avant c'était des gens qui
avaient le terrain ils devaient
construire une maison et ils se sont
disputés sur les plans ils sont
tellement disputé qu'ils ont divorcé moi
t'as pas été tenté d'acheter une maison
en tunisie pourquoi tu as acheté à
saint-paul maintenant chez moi c'est ici
c'est quoi le premier lieu pour toi qui
était associé à l'idée de vacances c'est
quel endroit la tunisie mais quel
endroit
un endroit qui s'appelle kheireddine et
à côté de pas très loin de la goulette
on avait une espèce de petite maison de
vacances comme un peu tu sais comme les
cabanons près de marseille mais un dans
ce genre là en fait avec une terrasse
sur la mer époux et c'était le paradis
toutes les façons de comme tous les
comme tous les enfants qu'on a arraché
un lieu d'enfance où il était bien
j'essaye de reproduire partout
les sensations que j'avais quand je me
souviens de vacances en grèce où j'ai
passé mon temps et mes copains il me dit
mais tu es fou pression monte à dire ah
tiens ça c'est comme à tunis
tiens ça c'est le bleu de tunis à tiens
ça c'est le blanc tunis ah tiens
aujourd'hui je me suis baigné comme à
tunis ou à des souvenirs le grand amour
de vacances j'aime pas parler de ma vie
mais il ya une histoire qui est drôle
qui avait arriver c'est que kim a après
qu'image pas en parler maintenant parce
que ça fait ya prescription
c'est que mon premier flirt elle était
plus vieille que moi alors bon on s'est
embrassés je savais pas mais on s'est
débrouillé jeu c'est de faire comme je
voyais dans les films et puis mes frères
on m'avait raconté comment on faisait à
peu près et puis évidemment j'ai essayé
de lui enlever son soutien gorge et j'ai
jamais réussi
elle ne m'a jamais dit ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui jean situation m'arriverait
je dirais écoute jean plectre au soutien
technique d'au moins une paire de
ciseaux j'ai la rage mais la juge et
demi je n'arrivais pas je savais c'était
une sté un enfer j'ai passé l'après-midi
sur le soutien gorge sur loup de la
fermeture en plus est comme ça m'a
tellement traumatisée je suis donné un
champion du monde des soutiens gorge
maintenant tu séjour un tous les
soutiens gorge avec une main parce que
j'ai passé après après cette histoire
chaque fois je passais devant un magasin
de lingerie je regardais tous les
soutiens et je regardais comment ça
s'ouvre et j'essayais de mémoriser et
après c'est devenu un jeu chaque fois
que j'étais avec une fille jeu
j'essaie de toucher le soutien-gorge
derrière et je vous paierai l'ouverture
je dis ça c'est ça c'est la numéro 4 et
j'ouvrirai dis moi tu as ouvert de
chansons de 2 qui tomba qui ont marqué
et et oui il y avait une chanson comme
mon père faisait tout le temps tournait
s'était tu me fais tourner la tête ça
mon manège à moi mon manager aimerait ça
et puis et maintenant de gilbert bécaud
vais-je faire ça ça me plaisait beaucoup
je m'étais souvent mais tu sais c'est
surtout des odeurs des moments la pêche
par exemple nous ont péché est
aujourd'hui à plus de poisson pour faire
ça on prenait les toiles de sacs de
pommes de terre en toile de jute beige
là on prenait de la mie de pain on
mettait ça depuis avec la friture qui
arrivait à damas à laisser entrer
on leur empêcher à la bouteille tu
prends une bouteille comme comme ça un
peu ouais comme ça mais incolore et tu
casses ici et tu mets un bouchon ici tu
n as oui et tu mets de l'eau de mer et
de la mie de pain et tu es tu là mais
c'était interdit et on mettait la
bouteille palois on la regardait à
surveiller on a tôt fait des petits
mulet comme ça et il fallait attraper
des émules et femelles pourquoi comme ça
les mâles arrive c'est par elle que chez
nous alors je vous rappelle qu'en
général les mâles je sais pas vous mais
pour les poissons c'est comme ça
[Musique]
le chanceuse autre mari a beaucoup de
chance
mais sa vie est oui
ah oui vous avez de la chance
ah oui ça vous l'avez dit c'est
exactement
ça va
vous êtes même carrément fait tout
je laisse moi entrer et en sortir
non mais pas me charmer j'ai passé l'âge
mais c'est pas vrai elle vous prennent
ou pour s'assurer les quelques prochains
jours ou pour s'assurer à présent j'en
ai tellement charmant s'est pas inquiété
pour ça non je ne m'inquiète pas pour ça
avant je mettais trop belle
cela s'est passé non valence du gazole y
en a plus c'est le signe d'un charmant
c'est vrai il est très très très beau on
viendrait me revoir c'est vrai tout çà
c'est vrai quand on
ça va mieux ah bon j'peux pas de
remonter le moral - peut-être oui ça va
pas au shopi cham
ah bon ça va alors on va savourer vocal
au programme d'aujourd'hui ont trouvé
mignonne ouais ouais
pirmin bien j'étais plus jeune on est
capable à n'importe quel âge ces
marchands comme on le comprend bien même
atteint 10 dans le monde le soir on joue
bien mais j'aurais plutôt bourgeois
abbaoui ça fait sur bas il faudra
essayer je suis du boulodrome est un
mais comment ce soir ce soir chez toi
faisable c'est vrai ce soir chez toi
non
sur la plage tu as déjà fait ça sur la
plage t'aimes pas sur le monde la mort
est toujours à wayne va t'appeler ouais
ouais ça regarde entendez souvent au
revoir c'est vrai quand tu t'appelles
vraiment vraiment à ça car et verra non
pas qu'on ait des halles a vraiment
c'est bien la bourre quand est ce que
raymond va me trouver ça
[Musique]
à comment quand tu as carrément on va me
trouver comment il fait ça
là bas je suis
ne plaît pas
mouais
un petit peu beaucoup mais quand une
fille
le fameux play simplement de l'approché
de lui parler
ouais ça m'a fait quelque chose et moi
ce que je ferai un petit peu ou beaucoup
c'est vrai je n'ai pas regardé
j'attends pavillon je n'ai pas bien joué
non non mais j'ai pas beaucoup encore
d'expérience c'est aura beaucoup
d'expérience toi on peut quand même evra
tu viens me chercher à 19 heures ce soir
je réfléchirai à la curée c'est vrai
je dis à chaque fois le son est déjà
plus là là là je n'aurai pas je
rencontre le jeune demoiselle est trop
fort à faire bon d'accord allait garder
sourire et vive la vie ciao
[Musique]
là c'était premières vacances depuis
combien de temps trois ans et c'est les
dernières avant quand même temps avant
je pense avant deux ans de quoi à peu
près 2 en mai
en même temps c'est important les
vacances c'est une autre manière de
travailler je peux réfléchir je peux tu
nous as tu des trucs soit en bateau
lance moment oui un peu mais moi je ne
suis pas quelqu'un qui nomme j'ai une
mémoire incroyable
et puis c'est faire n'importe quoi les
vacances c'est ça qui est bien c'est
c'est dire j'ai sommeil c'est dormir
c'est dire j'ai sommeil et je veux pas
dormir et tu dors pas c'est sortir
jusqu'à 8 heures du matin c'est c'est
fumer des cigarettes parce que je peux
quand je joue le spectacle je fume
beaucoup moins c'est il ya une liberté
incroyable
le spectacle c'est une contrainte c'est
une discipline infernale parce qu'on a
parce que le spectacle tous les jours
c'est la première parce que les gens qui
viennent voir ton spectre il n'était pas
là la veille il s'entraîne demain ça
peut arriver
est ce que mon québec tous les jours
mais globalement bon alors ils ont
jamais vu le truc est pour eux si t'es
pas bien
même si tu as joué sans toi là tu seras
nul donc il faut que tu sois bien tous
les jours et tous les jours tu arrives à
un endroit et tapas de vie tes copains
le samedi le dimanche tu travailles donc
tu vois très peu tes copains tu vois
très peu les gens mais c'est tellement
génial en même temps que bon ça va oui
oui un non mais moi je ne pourrais
jamais changé je pourrais jamais faire
un autre métier je pourrais c'est
impensable c'est impensable
j'aime trop ça et d'ailleurs c'est très
étrange
parce que j'aime encore plus ça qu'avant
j'ai remarqué que
ça manquait très vite
et puis et puis c'était plus en plus
important c'est peut-être le seul
endroit où je me sens pas dont on parle
je suis vachement sérieux je fais pas de
blague parce que souvent quand je fais
des émissions de télévision avant en
tout cas je me forçais à faire des
blagues je me forçais à faire des
blagues parce que j'avais l'impression
que c'était comme ça qu'il fallait être
là j'en voulais tu pensais que les gens
voulaient le voir comme ça ouais et je
vais je suis pas très à l'aise à la
télévision il ya plein de gens qui me
disent ah tiens on vous a vu dans une
émission vous aviez pas l'air à l'aise
mais je suis pas à l'aise parce que je
suis pas chez moi parce que chez moi
c'est une scène de théâtre
je sais pas moi j'étais bien là oui là
ça va sur la plage je sois pas il n'y a
pas de caméra l'acteur y a pas un mec
qui vous faut-il pas de questions
nouvelles total air et à parer de camer
be jeu mais je suis comme tout le monde
ça veut dire sortie de mon cadre je me
mets à jouer
un personne n'a plus envie de faire ça
disons que au début quand ont visé par
exemple c'est encore de la promise il
est souvent l'un je me suis amusée je
connaissais pas tous ah ouais ça
m'amusait beaucoup je me rendais pas
compte de ça et puis petit à petit avec
le temps la fraîcheur de ça il a envie
de faire ça comme c'est pas mon métier
je faisais ça pour m'amuser
oui j'allais la télé tout d'un coup
j'étais plus devant le magasin j'étais
dans la vitrine que ça me faisait
rigoler mois au bout d'un moment
bon ça arrêtez de me fasciner
et puis mon corps mon vrai métier c'est
pas ça et puis la télévision a beaucoup
changé la paix la télévision c'est un
problème c'est qu'il faut si tu vas à la
télé en essayant comme ça de faire des
blagues de faire le boujenah au bout
d'un moment tu tu totaux caricature oui
et là ça t'énerve soit trente ans de
caricatures non j'aime bien qu'on
caricature ce que j'aime pas c'est qu'il
ya une fausse vision des gens tu vois
quand on réduit les gens c'est ce que la
télévision et du leur et et puis et puis
c'est faux tu vois tu peux pas savoir le
nombre de gens qui viennent pas me voir
au spectacle heureusement il ya beaucoup
qui viennent me voir ce problème mais le
nombre de gens qui viennent pas me voir
parce qu'ils m'ont vu à la télé et qui
me disent ah ouais moi j'ai vu bouger
d'un vrai ça me plaît pas tu peux pas
savoir à tout le temps à la télé
exactement
tu peux pas savoir le nombre de gens qui
viennent me voir au spectacle qui vient
me voir après qu'ils me disent ah je ne
savais pas que c'était ça nous faisait
parce que la télévision dans mon cas moi
c'est pas le cas de tous les comics ne
restitue pas du tout mon travail parce
que moi je suis pas drôle dans la vie je
suis c'est des fois il dû croiser des
gens dans la rue ils te disent ah ouais
mais tu es moins de droit local hâter
les toits au [ __ ] de témoins drôle
mais fait le clown way fait le clown
n'est pas inconnu quand un raconteur et
puis j'aime bien
j'aime bien déconné mais c'est comme
dans la vie ça vient quand ça vient je
vais pas me forcer
c'est horrible de se forcer alors le
team jeudi mais je pas une machine
monsieur je sais pas moi je me
débrouille alors longtemps ça me fait de
la peine j'aime pas qu'il dise à la fin
at elle fait savoir
ouais je vois pas ce que tu aimes bien
aussi que les gens tu aimes bien tu sais
tu sais pas trop comment me débrouiller
avec ça c'est vachement compliqué et
puis je te dis la télévision a beaucoup
changé aussi on comment j'ai
l'impression si tu veux que que les
artistes à la télévision j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont moins à l'aise
qu'avant je crois pas être le seul
je crois que la télévision est devenue
une telle machine censée appris
énormément d'importance dans la vie des
gens maintenant la télé absolument avant
tu avais des gens qui disaient hier soir
j'ai vu un film j'ai lu un livre chez le
spectacle maintenant ils disent est ce
que tu as vu l'émission de dechavanne ou
les mini stage chez maguy et même la
télévision fait parler d'elle ça veut
dire que les animateurs de la télévision
est le meilleur type sur dans les
journaux il ya des magazines de plus en
plus sur la télévision
les comiques font des sketches sur la
télévision la télévision c'est devenu le
sujet d'ailleurs en bout de table
avant il y avait le père oui qui me
donnait la soupe
maintenant il arrêté l'école à la place
du père il ya la télé et va demander à
la télé de servir à sous et les gens ils
mangent comme ça et je me demande quand
ils font d'ailleurs ça a pris alors à
mon temps c'est formidable c'est un
outil de communication génial et en même
temps ça on ferme tout le monde dans le
même si ce n'est sa fait peur et les
moins en moins de gens qui sont
marginaux par rapport à la télé sur ton
sur ton bateau tu as là que la télé là
non tu vois par exemple une autre chose
qui me fait penser tu me parlais de deux
mois et de la télévision
il ya plein de gens qui que ça énerve
parce que des fois à la télé je parle de
tout et tu donnes ton avis sur tout et
ils disent ah mais celui-là une caste
éboueurs il parle dessus de tout il
s'intéresse il a un avis sur tout et
mais je trouve que c'est formidable
d'avoir d'être curieux ça veut pas dire
parce que j'ai envie de parler tous que
ce que je dis est intelligent je peux
dire des conneries gens disent souvent
le problème c'est mais quand tu te
retrouves pas intimes tu te poses des
questions surtout tu réponds et que tu
le journal ex tu t'intéresses si bien
que s'intéresser à tous j'ai pas envie
d'être un abruti qui dit ah non monsieur
roy en dehors du terrain je m'intéresse
à rien en quoi il ya une guerre en
croatie je sais pas ce que c'est la
guerre les pantalons excusez moi je
parle pas de ça sousse et ça serait bête
qu'est ce que tu vas faire là ce soir
maintenant la toux la loire pourrait
tuer dans une boîte tu vas retourner sur
ton bateau regardez les sept étoiles
qu'il faut avoir vu avant ce soir tu
peux te raccrocher pour les skippers ne
crois pas que tu les verras ce soir les
sept étoiles
tout à l'heure on a là aucune ouais ils
ont dit 2010 par oui non peut-être
demain soir on verra quoi il ya des
liens il ya une goutte comme toujours à
cette question je vais sortir peut-être
et ouais je sais pas je vais voilà c'est
ça la nouvelle bateau après oui bien sûr
il arrivera au bout mais non il ya un
type qui m'emmène avant alors rien il ya
un mec a qu'un petit bateau qui m'emmène
au bateau annoncé organisée il peut tout
arriver
[Musique]
quand tu mènes ça
la mena
[Musique]
et
m
guerre
[Musique]
ses fans
oh
c'est
[Musique]
ça
m
lee
[Musique]
ma
non
no money face aux fans
[Musique]
monte à ojai
ok
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
offre spéciale jakin seller certainement
monsieur tremblay j'occupe suite résolue
monsieur j'ai des remontées d'accent ma
mère était suisse alors ça n'est pas ce
qui est arrivé à la gare de lausanne
hier soir non un train monsieur
[Musique]
bonsoir marcel bauer gris ça va dans les
deux sens ils doivent arriver on est
toujours dit alors dis-moi tu as 44 ans
un suédois agriculteurs à collobrières
et ckoi que le broyeur c'est à quel
endroit la base de la capitale d'oman et
les chartes ayant pour mieux aurait pu
dire non classé ouais c'est vrai bon
super justement tu fais du vin moi je
fais du pays de 12 hectares c'est ça
fait du rosé et site occupé un peu les
sangliers dans la colline aussi ap
bavois d'engels goethe donne à l'automne
qu'est ce que tu vas faire oublier à des
petites misères commençait à s'ennuyer
comme un chien de garde la nuit la nuit
j'ai défendu d'une véranda pcot interdit
aux européennes a commencé à travailler
à quel âge a truck series encore à
l'école 12 ou 13 ans je travaille avec
un pagne qu'est ce que tu faisais la
vigne la colline le bois le lien vous
tous à ses descendants de liège delà de
la montagne parce qu'à l'époque à
l'épaule droite et d'exploiter le liège
les collines
ce potager du liège qui tournait vite
les fabriques et bien j'étais traitée à
que le voyez après à l'époque j'ai une
compo du la dernière aux fabrications
mais bon là moi j'étais encore jeune
mais non portés à cuers ont porté à qui
on sait maintenant c'est fini
il vient de le dire maintenant être 200
jeunes étrangers pourraient sa mère que
le bois hier le village et a fait
davantage aux habitants mais il ya là
des romans t on à 142 50 ans est-ce qu'à
l'époque il y avait beaucoup de travail
c'était riche et fort c'est moi parce
qu'il faut et tu avais les fabriques de
liage jusqu'à 4 1 titre en quatre quarts
temps fabrique derrière et puis le bois
c'est très riche tu avais des forêts de
pins syrie de pain ces spots et le pen
est squatté le liège tu faisais des
bouchons les chairs t1 et tout s'est tu
es riche
il y avait du travail tout ça c'est fini
a dit moi qu'est-ce qui a changé dans la
vie à collobrières depuis des dernières
levées mais c'est quoi
c'était une autre vie et puis il y avait
il y avait quand même une une autre
mentalité
et ça c'est malheureux parce que les
gens je trouve qu'ils cédé plus il se
rendait plus organisée il était plus
comment je pourrais plus solide et
endurance et sa chérie j'ai dû ça pour
ça mais toi comme j'avais 20 ans de sa
pensée à partir de collobrières
et j'ai été habitué à la campagne
je me suis mis à aider ta génération
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait les autres ils
sont restés ils sont partis eux flux
chaud non non non parce que je vous
parle peut être donné dans un mois comme
ça ni grave ni attaché sur les ordis et
oui quoi il était quand ils voient
arriver les parisiennes je te dis quoi
je sais très bien que maintenant il faut
que c'est le tourisme qui fait 8 points
de location porter dire ça se comprend
mais veegaete desservant les codes
barres au gîte mois pour être beau voilà
dit assailli les gens qui disaient fini
et comme tu as eu le feu la régie
commande ça le fera il faut d'abord
parler des journées en dix ans
ça a été une catastrophe et la
catastrophe a mais tout ça parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses qui rentrent à
gurs et
c'est le manque d'organisation et le bug
de tous ceux qui dirigera les les cocos
qui nous dirigent la is a atteint ce que
ce voeu que ça je prends de l'audience
parce que j'ai déjà dit et qu'il faut un
peu de savoir ce que c'est une colline à
savoir
voilà pourquoi nos fruits et le brûlot
d'un mais ils s'allument comment ces
feux qui les anime la bbc des pyromanes
les promoteurs immobiliers là j'ai
jamais vu personne
on va rire au mieux je suis là je crois
pas qu'il y ait dans l'humour étrange ça
mais combien de temps pour repousser
après une vie ouais bah non c'est une
vie c'est toute une vie et l'histoire
des contre-feux ces coins là le soir du
compte je suis content on veut et c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus efficace pour
arrêter ce soir contre fait parce que
les gens ils savent pas ce qu ont trop
peur il faut déjà fait tenir par des
gens de métier parce que quand au feu
peut être aussi des heureux
jeanne qui se trouve dans la colline
parce que on n'abîme pas quand on fait
n'importe où n'importe comment
quand on veut ce n'est une tenir 20 par
des gens de métier tu calcules tu as ton
feu qui arrive aux parias bleus poussée
par la vague
comment ça bon on est une équipe là je
peux te retrouver
aussi comme un ami et on était très peu
un et bon tu commences à faire
comprendre aux banquiers tu fais une
satire du groupe hôtelier de robin qui
ont dit c'est bien
et après tu commences apportions duo en
allumant doucement doucement et tu fais
des centres veux et tu fais rentrer et
ont peur du surnaturel mondial u20
curieux c'est un fait que tu allumes toi
et tu veux que tu allumes de façon que
lorsque le gros feu arrivera que ce feu
que tu a allumé à rentrer sain c'est
qu'entre 200 m
donc trouvons rien à brûler l'autre
salon automatique goren turlure ce soit
en fait tu la lune et le soleil
il va doucement il va de ce mail à 12
sur 20 99 sur sa de l'auto n'ayant
d'yeux en étant une équipe a déjà deux
métiers le feu a lancé 12 20 boules
rouges quand il a volé 150 200 m le feu
arrive au bout et il sera content tu les
était comme ça le feu moi je vais banale
et ils pourront rentrer donc trouver ou
à les afriques
mais c'est interdit les contre-feux
quand même a donc ça j'aimerais son
arbre
pourquoi mais c'était illégal il a
beaucoup fatigué grave au courrier
[Musique]
vous rendez vous compte monsieur d'un
petit grain de sable peut gripper un
engrenage ce même grain de sable
similaire pratiquement identiques peu
avec l'aide d'un peu d'eau bloquer tout
un pays pendant un mois
on appelle ça des vacances il y en a
même qui après scission bizarre non
je suis plus mis à part
non je voulais juste vous parlez 5
et
[Musique]
il y a
allongée sur la plage les cheveux
dans les yeux
et le nez
dans le sable
on est bien
tous les deux c'est l'été les vacances
oh mon dieu
quelque chose
une demi heure
le sommeil
il y a
le sommet
ma cabane
c'est un beau jeu
m
hualan tous les jours
c'est dimanche et nous donne
à midi
[Musique]
et sur la place
et de l'autre âge
j'en doute
[Musique]
montceau
chanteur
sous son ère
et le soir tous ensemble
ah mais
de chercher
il parle de vacances
et d'amour
de chance en chantant
ca
le soirée
[Musique]
en chantant
c est le soleil
allez
quelque part
[Musique]
et le soir
attachant
[Musique]
un gun
et le plus
donne
nous aurons
[Musique]
un nouveau
900 m françois deguelt bonsoir bonsoir
alors dit moi le ciel le soleil et la
mer c'était en quelle année là bas
c'était a longtemps motors a fait
c'était en 1965
c'est à dire non c'est pas d'hier et
bientôt 30 ans je sais pas mais ça nous
a aussi way qui a écrit cette chanson
c'est moi
paroles et musiques pas tu te souviens
la façon dont il a composé le la créa
travaux souvent oui c'était à paris un
jour de pluie dans la voiture j'étais
assise à l'arrière
il ya eu une copine qui était assise à
l'avant juste après midi j'ai vu trois
mots comme cela comme comme les fables
de la fontaine cher la belette et puis
je vais vous fredonnez donc salaires
elle m'a dit tu devrais garder cette
musique parce que c'est ça va mal
voilà
c'était un énorme succès populaire ouais
tu sais combien de disques vendus
je crois que ça a dépassé 300 milles 10
47 beaucoup à l'époque au début cela a
vendu 158 vite fait ouais
puis après ça a été réédité comme disait
jean compte en parlant surtout quelle
chanson c'est la chanson qui nourrit
ouais c'est ça je sais comment ça tu as
rapporté au total
abbas après mon loyer mon gaz de
l'électricité et comme j'habite les
autres c'est moins cher et au sabre
attentes à peu près 150 euros par mois
un peu problème mais le ciel le soleil
et la mer et tarifs de le siffler en
trois ans
ah non non tu as tu la chambre par la
dépouille sur ton bateau ça a été tu en
plus gros succès oui un oui à prêter
essayer de faire parler ici de refaire
le coup après toujours et c'est vrai ce
que tu as fait une chanson qui
s'appelait paris c'est trop loin de la
mer oui un peu ce à quoi tu as essayé de
demain je me souviens qu'à l'époque où
j'ai fait cette chanson dutronc avait
fait j'aime les filles ouais c'est la
même vie et c'est celle de goudron qui a
marché
ouais bon
l'état fait le bal de la marine alors
c'était comment le bal de la marine
était fait quoi avant le ciel le soleil
et la mer dans ta vie c'était déjà un
chanteur connu ouais ouais je le fais
l'eurovision deux fois ouais j'ai
commencé dans les cabarets non cabaret
oui très étonnant dans ton histoire
c'est que quand tu as fait le ciel le
soleil et la mer était sur le point
d'arrêter car tu voulais tu vois je
voulais arrêter toute l avais marre ça
marchait pas très bien finalement
non c'est pas ça c'est pas que ça
marchait pas gay mais tous les gens qui
étaient dans le métier avant le rush
quoi 42 n'ont pas bu rock mobilier et un
soir j'étais meutrier avec des copains
d'europe disaient tous est souhaitée va
changer considérablement
je crois que que tous les gars qui
étaient là ça va disparaître et moi
n'est pas que j'avais 30 ans je me suis
30 ans bon ça va ça nous sommes de droit
et puis faire le tri
et puis bon la chanson est sortie mais
s'attachera à changer ta vie
complètement mais si on a rendu ses bras
gagné tellement de thunes que c'était
rendu seniors n'ont pas ça non mais il
ya des gens qui sont accrochés par le
travail qu'ils ne pensent qu'à ça qui
vivent dans le métier qui couchent dans
le métier
bon et puis elle a d'autres qui
préfèrent j'ai rêvé pouvoir justement
parce qu'alors avant le le ciel le
soleil et la mer on a vu ce que tu
faisais mais après ouais ouais
après c'est ça c'est à dire après tu as
fais de la voile déjà tu habitais sur
une péniche été acheté un bateau avec
cette chanson non oui c'est vrai quoi
dans ces années qu'ils ont
vie l'immense succès du ciel le soleil
et la mer est quand même des ennuis on a
parlé de querelles on a parlé de
bagarres on a parlé de télécoms des
histoires un peu non pourrais-tu picoler
la main le brûle tout le monde mais ce
n'était pas garde
huawei ouais t'as plus un peu plus mais
un jour un juge s'était 13e chambre
correctionnelle je lui ai dit monsieur
vue je vous donne ma parole que vous ne
me verrez
et depuis ses débuts par le staff et
l'emportent et pourrais tu penses que tu
aies jamais devenu une grande vedette
les normes peut être parce que tu as
composé quand même quelques belles
chansons que j'avais un physique
excellent comment ce serait que jamais
crevé le plafond parce que parce que
j'avais pas le courage nécessaire
pour vivre le quotidien
et puis
pour être de grandes vedettes il faut il
faut travailler tous les jours enfin
travailler ont commandé à travailler sa
technique travailler son personnage se
prendre pour ces 13 janvier quand on
rencontre un homme qui se prend pour le
nom qu'il affiche n'arrivait pas ça
tient pas ça m'emmerde
ah oui c'est évident dit vous pouvez 10
mai avec une bonne et c'est toujours moi
je moi je
et moi ça m'embête d'attenté des come
back non non tu as peu tu t'es pas dit à
un moment je vais bosser comme dax c'est
toujours un peu le hasard en fait
finalement il n'y a qu'une fois où tu as
vraiment baisser les bras c'est quand
une femme tu as quitté a eu un gros
chagrin d'amour
après s'il arrive à tous les besoins et
là tu as été dépressif pour le couvert
on devrait pas beaucoup plus qu'après le
à 1 1 ça ça arrive à tous les hommes et
si ça n'arrive pas dans la vie dans nos
rues c'est une vie très triste
enfin et c'est toujours fait passer ta
vie amoureuse avant ta vie
professionnelle non oui un oui vous
m'aviez affective à ce que me souviens
quand j'étais petit françois deguelt
pour moi il y avait le ciel le soleil et
la mer bien sûr et tu étais avec dora
deux jeunes filles formidables dort avec
notre fils d'high coûte c'est avec dora
doll que tu es belle fille de l'époque
non on le fils était une somme de saab
après cette histoire d'amour donc
malheureuse qui a fait une dépression
nerveuse et a perdu 18 kilos ce n'était
pas rien quand même 18 kg serait ouais
tu allais voir un toubib d'un docteur
était tombé amoureux du docteur
lorsqu'il faut préciser quand même c'est
que c'était une femme
ah oui quand même non mais oh oui cher
qu'avec ce toubib enfin c'est cette
femme docteur depuis vous êtes plus
quittés
vous viviez pas ensemble vous voyez
grand voile sombre et une fois par jour
quand même non oui où il m'attend non
pas tant aux téléphones
ouais ouais tu fais ta journée tu écris
des chansons j'ai écrite j'ai un petit
peu
j'ai écrit quelques chansons cet hiver
et puis j'écris un livre qui n'est pas
un livre de souvenirs parce que j'ai
bien précisé dans ce livre que on n'a
que des souvenirs de sunu quand on va
raconter ses souvenirs on va l'appeler
souvenir de ses débuts et qu'il faut se
méfier
et puis je pense à elle je veux pas
faire le savant je pense à un mot de
platon qui disait que le temps n'était
que l'image mobile de l'éternité et je
crois quand on comprend bien ça on sent
qu'on est des mots suivants on n'est
plus très violent tu écris tes chansons
tu fais du bateau je suis voix pull
jaune e boit pas ouais je ne vois pas
parce qu'un homme qui ne voient plus
c'est un homme qui ne boit plus depuis
trois mois alors on dit je ne bois plus
bien qu intervient de s'arrêter
longtemps on dit je ne vois pas ça fait
plus chic
tu as des projets la wii cet hiver je
vais refaire du cabaret assez bien trois
mois est la plus forte à la villa des
rapaces et bien c'est le plus grand
cabaret l'échangé de la ville de huy on
est ravi pour toi dis moi tu as quel âge
j'ai 59 ans et demi
[Musique]
la romana avait plein de petites q1
voilà voulez vous mettre la wii voilà et
là vous avez les petits culs l'un
pouvait mater et tous aient compris les
petits culs c'est d'ailleurs encore des
cultures ils regardent encore vécu ces
boues vous êtes curieux vous sentez le
pognon on sait qu'on va vous taxer tous
bords ont produit ce n'est mettez-vous
la whey
il y en a quand même john a enfin vous
même pendant les mauvaises années vous
êtes bons à plumes et installez-vous
mais non madame
on est là pour vous tirer votre blé à
moi je vous le dis je me met en
confiance c'est le but du jeu donc dès
que vous ouvrez votre sac à main
objet rien d'accord voulez un petit
cocktail de jus de fruit de huit enfants
non d'accord le seul truc que je vous
demanderai en cours de saison quand vous
aurez plus de blesser de nous le dire
pour qu on vous vire de la plage
comprennent d'autres gens un plus mais
un ayez l'honnêteté de nous le dire en
cours de saison 1
ça sera pas ici un bon jeu donnait le
nom vous faites pas chier que le
pourboire en obtenant une gourmette à
une boucle d'oreille vous avez un des
piliers de la monnaie
tout à l'heure ils étaient les bonnes
laquelle laquelle je crois ou dit allez
bonne volée à l'eau froide tout ça hein
je pense que vous aviez vu une gamine
qui était bonne deux parasols d'accord
d'accord ça fait 7 107 106 et 1400
reprendre parasols vous allez nique et
votre femme vous même oui ok donc j'ai
des commandes philippe merci philippe il
va là il va [ __ ] lui-même et c'est pas
trop dur la vie de milliardaire et pas
des moments c'est fatigant des primes en
tout cas j'étais un peu jaune oui mais
maintenant ça facile tout cet argent et
tous les fans ouais c'est dix ou si un
cd souci oui oui oui
un jour on s'achète un iota gérance
après chacune villa va [ __ ] les
gonzesses tout le temps tout le temps
sur ce qu'on va faire un truc moi je
vais faire milliardaire tu vas me filer
tout ton pognon et moi je te filer ma
chemise et tu vas faire plagistes et on
va voir si tu peux refaire milliardaire
en partant de plagistes est d'accord
[Musique]
savait que le sexe alors est ce un sujet
absolument tabou dans les émissions de
notre chardy sont je respecterai donc sa
pudeur éviterait tout commentaire sur
sera complètement hauts-de-seine les
stocks macek sautonne paul joe
[Musique]
jacky c'est quoi pour vous le meilleur
moment dans la mort c'est quand on monte
les escaliers monsieur mais pékin 10
personnes monsieur j'habite au rez de
chaussée
[Musique]
alors on devrait
et livre de la semaine alors je vais
dire tirer c'est que on est en plein été
ouais mais qu'est ce qu'on fait en
étaient en lice sur la plage exactement
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait aussi
eh ben je vais dire ce qu'on veut on
peut donner l'eau ben bella dans sap la
bourrique et godet jabr était en pro gay
gobaille et nous pille sonné 10 est
courte et vergers rivaux chemise est
bénigne et pour l'ief les braies ballet
bistoquet et carrioles et j'ai peur de
comprendre voilà ouais
eh ben ça c'est un bouquet de jean
claude carrière écrivain scénariste
scénariste de babel de ta mort et qui a
fait un merveilleux bouquin qui est une
espèce de dictionnaires de lexique du
mot inconvenant il a appelé les mots et
la chose et il le thrace et c'est très
joli issers que tous les maux français
ancien et moderne pour dire la chance à
tous les états et la chose et s'est mis
la presse que c'est la plus constante
que nous les français ne sont que vous
jouez à mayran l'amour et spar et les
plus gros les plus formidables bonjour
mes meilleurs pour en parler
voilà ouais on est les meilleurs en ce
qui concerne la langue mais l'acte je ne
sais pas en tout cas pour la langue un
fantastique tu as tous les aspects de la
chose et je désire il a recensé à peu
près je sais pas mieux vaut mille mots
et ses magnifiques parce que c'est
c'est une poésie formidable là vraiment
pour une fois il faut que je cite parce
que je ne peux pas ne pas citer par
exemple qu'on l'appelle là tu sais si
caractéristique est la femme est bien
regarde le clou le nerf le bras le doigt
le 11e doit le doigt qui n'a pas non
plus le fifre le fait que critiquer
l'ergot la lave est le petit frère le
honte
la clé de contact la chief je sais quand
ça va pas le foulard la flanelle le
pouce ou le rétrécit quelque chose en
moi de rétrécir
ça arrive à tout le monde et ça c'est
très joli parce que jean claude carrière
nous a fait vraiment quelque chose à
lire en vacances parce que là comme ça
pourrait lancer à quelqu un m a donc
rétréci
voilà et puis l'autre c'est votre ami le
frère celui qu'on regrette pierre
desproges de le projeter à écrire
merveilleux dictionnaire un usage des
mal pensants lors formidable c'est le
grand des proches d'eux qui a quand même
qui a dit le premier
faut-il choisir entre la gauche et la
droite entre mon veston blanc et mon
veston rouge et c'est lui qui a dit
cette phrase admirable jeu il à plus
d'humanité dans l'oeil de mon chien
quand elle remue la queue que dans la
queue de pelle 4e but son oeil du
desproges plus réduit et c'est un des
cas absolument magnifique charmant sympa
plein d'humour et plein de les proches
et les proches
on le regrettera jamais assez ça fait
deux livres alors pour cette semaine ça
fait de lait pour cette semaine et on
peut sur vous a ajouté un petit livre
très sympa de thierry colson qui
s'appelle guide de la mer doivent encore
un c'est que thierry cros on avait écrit
avec jean christophe laurent terre un
guide de la merde heures comment
emmerder votre base en plus et ben là il
a fait le guide de l'emmerdeur en
vacances et quand vous voyez un
emmerdeur attention avec ce livre
juillet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien de rien
non bonsoir merci d'avoir passé cette
soirée avec nous au bar de la plage
prochaine ouverture samedi prochain
salut bande d'hommes
non
je ne regrette rien
[Musique]
maillé
oubliée je vais tout du massé a vécu
mais j'ai bien lu mille feux et chagrin
les plaisirs je n'ai plus besoin de
balayer mes amours avec l'inde révolue
ben ali bhutto jour je repars à zéro
[Musique]
dans l'air de rien dans
je le regrette rien
il vient
[Musique]
dans ma fait musulmane tous avaient bien
l'erreur
au grand jeu philips bar de la plage la
question était où va chanter françois
deguelt à la rentrée et la réponse à la
villa d'este
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui ça commence
m
[Musique]
vous héritez nous ont été des boucs six
écrans 36 centimes mise en veille
automatique est programmable
bravo
antenne 2 et philips vous ont présenté
le bar de la plage l'émission d'été de
thierry ardisson
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou